[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
face à la crypte du mont valérien vous
propose 17 fusillés de la résistance le
général de gaulle a comme chaque année
en cette date anniversaire ranimer la
flamme sacrée pugilat fraternellement
saluer les compagnons de la libération
et s'est mêlé à la foule il ya 21 ans à
cette même date la france n'avait pas
abdiqué
après les fatigues protocolaire de paris
de vienne et de londres mais c'est
jacqueline kennedy a fait un crochet par
la grèce où elle a été reçue par le roi
paul et la reine frederick à
[Musique]
et
la première dame des etats-unis à
visiter en toute simplicité les ruines
de l'acropole et après avoir déclaré
qu'elle était pleine d'admiration pour
la grèce elle a formé le projet d'y
envoyer ses enfants en vacances
[Musique]
et
cette image du président kennedy
utilisant le monde charles de l'aéroport
pour descendre de son avion a beaucoup
ému l'amérique
rien de grave ont affirmé les médecins
le tout les américains qui a
impressionné la paire de béquilles
voudrait désormais voir leurs jeunes
présidents se ménager davantage et se
reposer plus souvent
[Applaudissements]
la visite que la pince renier la
princesse grace de monaco ont rendu à
l'irlande raquet aussi pour la princesse
une sorte de retour aux sources
l'irlande se trouve être en effet le
berceau de la famille kelly il n'y a
guère que 80 ans que le grand père de la
princesse grace s'expatria pour
l'amérique
voilà pourquoi les irlandais ont pu à
travers les quelques cinquante mille
kelly que l'on dénombre encore en
irlande avoir la sensation de retrouver
dans l'hôte du président de valera une
parente lointaine
[Musique]
il ya maintenant deux ans qui a commencé
du côté français ce 13e travail
d'hercule
ouvrir une route sous le plus haut
sommet d'europe deux ans que les
compresseurs de 1900 chauveau fabrique
l'air comprimé nécessaires à la
machinerie qui travaillent dans les
entrailles de la montagne
chaque jour depuis les hommes du tunnel
sont allés retrouver leur chantier
souterrain
quelques mètres plus loin que la veille
aujourd'hui des 11 km 6 ans les français
ont grignoté 3500 mètres soit 352 plus
que l'équipe italienne qui commença à
huit mois plus tôt
[Musique]
cette avance les équipes françaises la
doivent au jumbo énorme bâti à trois
étages hérisset de 16 perforatrice qui
attaquent la roche simultanément
l'action des explosifs disposés dans les
140 pour la 6 pers et ouvrent chaque
fois une brèche de 4 m
soit 750 tonnes de matériaux que deux
pelles mécaniques ont ensuite à évacuer
relayé par les tapis roulants
et 90 wagonnets ainsi le chantier avance
de 7 à 8 mètres par jour sous 3000
mètres de montagne
[Musique]
cependant vers l'amont cette image
infernal s'apaisent c'est ici un autre
chantier et la roche torture et fait
place à la voûte de béton le tunnel a
déjà pris sa forme définitive celle que
connaîtront les automobilistes de 1963
car il faudra attendre cette date pour
voir les touristes succédé aux camions
sur la route qui mènera de chameau
knicks en italie à travers le mont blanc
[Musique]
chaque jour a vu une nouvelle cité
bretonne investi par les commandos
d'agriculteurs guingamp après morlaix
lannion et pontivy à pontivy pour la
première fois la manifestation devait
dégénérer en violences que veulent donc
ses hommes en colère des satisfactions
immédiates
certes mais derrière cette jacquerie se
profile nous l'avons constaté la semaine
dernière tout un problème breton un
problème qui dépasse le prix de la pomme
de terre
malgré les 12 cents tracteurs des
manifestants déchaînés de pontivy c'est
le problème de la bretagne déshérités
et si les paysans bretons sans
s'attaquer aux lignes téléphoniques
c'est paradoxalement pour protester
contre leur rareté que les châteaux
d'eau phillies de pousser les fils
électriques de tendre leurs toiles nous
allons voir que la bretagne ne manque
pourtant pas de chance pour rattraper
son retard
s'il est vrai que le revenu de 50 % des
agriculteurs bretons est inférieur au
salaire d'une manoeuvre léger c'est en
bretagne aussi qu'on trouve les fermes
modèles les mieux équipés
[Musique]
la production agricole bretonne est en
passe de dépasser la moitié de la
production totale de la france la pêche
de son côté n'est pas seulement une
attraction pour touristes
mais j'en atout important qui peut
toujours être joué
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que
si les pêcheurs bretons ont eu de la
peine à sortir de leurs traditions
artisanales les fabriques de lorient
débite aujourd'hui des centaines de
tonnes de glace quotidiennement des
chalutiers équipés de radios et de
sondes pour la détection des bancs de
poissons font désormais la loi et la
modernisation de la flotte bretonne qui
entre deux chiffres 8000 navire en 39
ramener 81 mille tonnes de poissons 5000
navire maintenant on ramène 150 mille
tonnes
à la modernisation de la flotte il faut
ajouter aussi l'aménagement des
campagnes de pêche qui permet d'étaler
sur l'année des arrivages qu'ils
n'étaient que saisonnier et si la
tradition de la criée garde toujours sa
place dans les moeurs de la pêche
l'industrie des conserves peut
aujourd'hui la plupart du temps
fonctionné à plein temps c'est du reste
de l'industrie que la bretagne peut
attendre beaucoup
[Musique]
les exemples de décentralisation
industrielle vers la bretagne se sont
jusqu'ici compté lusine flaminaire en
est un avec ses 700 ouvriers
elle a fait d'heureux dont l'une des
capitales européennes du briquet
m
il faudrait 10 il faudrait 20 redon nous
verrons prochainement les espoirs que la
bretagne peut nourrir dans ce domaine
moyennant quoi une autre carte bretonne
qui s'appelle brest pourrait être joué
doté d'un arrière pays industrialisés
brest qui doit à la guerre d'être une
ville toute neuve pourrait prétendre un
autre avenir que celui de port militaire
[Musique]
le belge olivier gendebien et d'allemand
von trips ce rêve
l'américain phil hill plus prosaïque et
déjà au volant de sa ferrari il est le
premier dans sa voiture au départ du
grand prix de belgique il sera encore le
premier à l'arrivée
certes les deux rêveurs gendebien iphone
thrips ne vont pas lui laisser le temps
de respirer il devra appuyer à fond sur
l'accélérateur
tout cela se passe à plus de 200 6 de
moyenne
ou d'un fil et les femmes clipse d'une
terre numéro 6 juin devient numéro 8
viala que des fils harry car ce grand
prix belgique c'est le triomphe des
voitures italiennes qui prennent les
quatre premières places
quant à phil hill il pourrait bien être
cette année le premier pilote américain
champion du monde
[Musique]
toujours de la pointe du progrès voilà
ce que vous propose cette année les
américains pour vos vacances tout
d'abord des jolies filles et puis ce
petit divertissement
ça ne demande pas des qualités
intellectuelles exceptionnelles ce n'est
pas dangereux enfin ça peut se pratiquer
n'importe où pourvu que ce soit en
pleine et une natte de plastique spécial
un peu au dessus voilà comment on trouve
son âme d'enfant
il paraît que ce jeu va faire fureur sur
les plages du monde entier cet été
pourquoi pas après tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]